Grazie.
Ve lo presento con qualche riga sua di ricordi di infanzia.
C'era una volta un ragazzino, viveva nel paese più ingiusto del mondo, governato da individui che da ogni punto di vista umano dovevano essere considerati dei degenerati.
E c'era una città, la più bella città sulla faccia della terra, con un immenso fiume grigio.
Lungo quel fiume sorgevano magnifici palazzi, con facciate stupende.
Di buon mattino, quando il cielo era ancora pieno di stelle, il ragazzino si alzava e dopo aver fatto colazione con una tazza di tè e un uovo,
accompagnato dalla voce della radio che annunciava un uovo primato nella fusione dell'acciaio,
seguito dal coro dell'esercito che cantava un inno al capo, il cui ritratto era appeso al muro, sopra il letto ancora caldo,
si metteva a correre lungo l'argine coperto di neve per arrivare a scuola.
Si precipitava nell'atrio, buttava il berretto e il cappotto su un gancio e volava su per la scala e dentro la sua aula.
È uno stanzone con tre file di banchi, un ritratto del capo alla parete dietro la sedia dell'insegnante,
una carta con due emisferi, dei quali solo uno è legale.
Il ragazzino va a sedersi, apre la cartella, mette sul banco la penna e il quaderno,
alza il viso e si prepara ad ascoltare il bla bla.
Così Iosef Brodsky, appunto, uno dei grandi poeti del Novecento, premio Nobel per la letteratura nel 1987,
rievoca la sua infanzia a Leningrado, la città più bella sulla faccia della terra,
nell'Unione Sovietica di Stalin fra gli anni 40 e 50, il paese più ingiusto del mondo.
Iosef Brodsky, che potremmo anche chiamare Joseph, perché nella seconda parte della sua vita,
che poi è stata in realtà davvero una seconda vita, così diversa dalla precedente che c'è da chiedersi come ha fatto a reggere,
nella seconda parte della sua vita Brodsky è stato esiliato dall'Unione Sovietica,
è vissuto negli Stati Uniti, è diventato americano, ha scritto anche in inglese,
ma la poesia ha sempre continuato a scriverla in russo.
A quel punto si presentava così, io sono ebreo, poeta russo, saggista inglese e cittadino americano.
Quanto al saggista inglese, sarai ingeneroso, non volevo citarlo, ma lo dirò.
In un'intervista Brodsky ha anche detto, sì sì, certo che scrivo saggi, pagano benissimo alle riviste americane,
quindi sì, i saggi li scrivo in inglese. Devo dire che scrivere saggi è una forma di prostituzione.
E' nato dunque a Leningrado, che oggi si chiama di nuovo Pietroburgo,
e che lui detestava chiamare Leningrado, come detestava qualunque cosa che ricordasse il potere sovietico.
Lui, come tutti gli abitanti della città, in realtà ha sempre continuato a chiamarla Peter, come la chiamavano già ai tempi degli zar.
E' nato a Leningrado il 24 maggio 1940.
Per chi non avesse proprio in mente, il 24 maggio 1940, credo che sia grossomodo il giorno in cui le Panzerdivisionen arrivano alla manica,
tagliando fuori l'esercito inglese a Dunkirk.
E in pieno svolgimento l'invasione tedesca della Francia, Hitler sta stravincendo la Seconda Guerra Mondiale.
E l'anno prossimo toccherà alla Russia.
Ve lo dico perché già il fatto che Josef Brodsky sia sopravvissuto all'infanzia è una specie di miracolo.
Perché nasce a Leningrado e il 22 giugno del 41 scatta l'invasione tedesca,
e dopo pochi mesi Leningrado è assediata dai tedeschi.
L'ho già detto ieri parlando di Anna Akhmatova, ma è un fatto talmente grosso nella storia della Russia
che comunque lo incontri da tutte le parti, non c'è niente da fare.
L'assedio di Leningrado.
L'assedio, la bloccada, come dicono i russi, dura più di due anni.
E per i primi cinque mesi questa città di due milioni di abitanti è completamente isolata.
Non entra niente.
In quell'inverno tra il 40 e il 41 muore di fame almeno un quarto della popolazione di Leningrado.
Cinque, seicentomila persone.
Brodsky, che appunto odiava il nome Leningrado, però ha detto
quell'assedio e quei morti sono l'unica cosa che dà un senso al nome Leningrado.
Dopotutto non ti puoi mica mettere a discutere con le scritte sulle tombe.
Brodsky è un anno allo scoppio della guerra e per tutta la guerra lui e sua madre rimangono soli
perché il padre è ufficiale.
La mamma è impiegata.
Il padre, che ha due lauree, è capitano della marina militare, fotografo di guerra
e per tutti quegli anni è in mare.
Lo mandano addirittura in Cina a un certo punto, con incarichi anche importanti.
E Iosif è a Leningrado, sopravvive ai primi mesi dell'assedio e alla morte per fame.
Poi quando diventa possibile cominciare a evacuare i civili, anche la mamma e il bambino vengono evacuati.
Torneranno nel 44, quando ormai il blocco è interrotto.
Anche se sembra impossibile, Iosif, ricordiamolo, è nato nel 40.
Gli anni tremendi dell'assedio sono il 41-42.
Lui se ne ricordava.
Mia madre che mi trascina di sera per le strade morte e coperte di neve.
Le luci della contraerea che tracciano dei disegni che sembravano numeri romani.
Il rumore lontano dei cannoni.
Ricordo i bombardamenti aerei sbirciati dalla cantina.
I prigionieri tedeschi che sfilano per le strade, scortati dai soldati russi.
Il colore delle uniformi.
Queste cose, ricordo.
I fuochi d'artificio per la riconquista di questa o quella città.
E poi ovviamente i fuochi d'artificio del 9 maggio 1945.
Il giorno della vittoria.
E la folla straripante.
Brodsky nella sua maturità al sicuro in America
ha spesso rievocato la sua infanzia e i suoi genitori.
Che non ha mai più rivisto dopo essere stato espulso dall'Unione Sovietica
a 32 anni, nel 72.
Ricorda le divise della marina, i cappotti neri con i bottoni d'oro
che lo emozionavano.
Dice il bambino era un piccolo patriota.
Adorava i modellini di navi da guerra, gli aerei da guerra,
le statue degli ammiragli al museo della marina a Leningrado.
Ricorda anche la povertà estrema della vita.
Nell'Unione Sovietica uscita vittoriosa dalla guerra,
ma in realtà spezzata, ridotta a una povertà terrificante.
Il primo pane bianco.
Avevo sette anni.
Ricordo lo sguardo di mia madre e di mia zia
in quell'occasione così rara.
Pane bianco.
Nel 1947.
Vivono in una stanza e mezzo,
in un alloggio in comune.
Un altro luogo classico della vita sovietica
e della letteratura sovietica.
Con la rivoluzione, anche questo mi sa che l'ho già detto ieri,
ma qui ci torniamo un po' più da vicino,
perché veramente la famiglia Brodsky,
questa esperienza della vita nella casa in comune con altri,
l'ha vissuta per tanto tempo.
Cosa succede?
Succede che questi alloggi in comune,
in cui vivi con altre famiglie,
e la cucina è in comune,
e il cesso è in comune,
e però sono in genere alloggi
in immensi e lussuosissimi palazzi nobiliari,
perché sono i palazzi nobiliari
che sono stati confiscati e distribuiti.
E quindi i Brodsky vivono
in uno dei palazzi più lussuosi di Pietroburgo,
un palazzo costruito lì sul balcone.
È il papà che è fotografo,
che l'ha fotografato da ragazzo.
Un palazzo dell'inizio del Novecento
e dice Brodsky,
Anna Akhmatova mi raccontò una volta
che i suoi genitori la portavano in carrozza
a vedere quella meraviglia.
I soffitti alti 4 metri,
i balconi, i mobili monumentali,
decorazioni a stucco,
però stanno in tre, in 40 metri quadri,
e la cucina e il bagno
sono in comune con altre famiglie.
E Brodsky, come altri scrittori russi,
ha scritto che quel modo di vivere,
che così tante famiglie
hanno dovuto condividere per decenni,
ha avuto un impatto enorme sulla vita russa.
Cito.
Da circa tre generazioni,
i russi vivono in appartamenti comuni
e in stanze troppo strette,
e i nostri genitori facevano l'amore
mentre noi fingevamo di dormire.
Poi ci fu una guerra.
Padri assenti o mutilati,
madri assatanate,
bugie ufficiali a scuola
e ufficiose a casa.
Ora in realtà il Brodsky maturo in America
negli anni 70, 80, 90,
quando parla della sua famiglia
e perfino della comunalca,
dell'alloggio in comune,
in realtà si intenerisce.
E i suoi ricordi sono dolcissimi.
Mentre è pieno di rabbia
quando parla delle condizioni materiali di vita,
della propaganda
e soprattutto della scuola che odiava.
E se c'era una cosa che odiava ancora di più della scuola
erano i campi estivi dei pionieri,
i boy scout sovietici.
Inverni duri, vestiti orrendi.
Quando facevi la pipì a letto al campo estivo
e Brodsky era un bambino che faceva la pipì a letto
e un ragazzino che faceva la pipì a letto,
ci torneremo.
Quando facevi la pipì a letto al campo estivo
esponevano le tue lenzuola bagnate
davanti a tutti gli altri,
mentre la bandiera rossa sventolava
dal pennone del campo.
Ha un pessimo ricordo degli insegnanti,
dei compagni della scuola.
In realtà il punto è che
qualunque fossero i difetti della scuola sovietica
Iosef odiava la scuola in assoluto.
Era uno di quei bambini che per definizione
odiano andare a scuola.
Odiava in particolare, come lo capisco,
l'educazione fisica.
Puzzavamo parecchio,
non ci si lavava con grande cura.
La cultura della doccia quotidiana
non esisteva in Russia.
Una delle grandi scoperte
quando è arrivato in America, no?
Questi matti fanno la doccia tutti i giorni.
Poi quella specie di atmosfera da competizione
si aveva il dovere di emergere
e a me la cosa non piaceva granché.
Però, a essere sinceri, appunto, va detto
andare a scuola non gli sarebbe piaciuto da nessuna parte,
non solo in Russia.
La cosa più terribile
era doversi alzare così presto la mattina.
Stranamente ricorda anche
la precocità del desiderio sessuale.
A dieci anni smaniavamo tutti per le nostre insegnanti.
Gli insegnanti erano quasi tutte donne.
Gli uomini erano morti in guerra.
Brodsky, peraltro, attenzione,
mentre ricorda spesso, appunto,
un'infanzia felice con i genitori,
ma infelice per tutto il resto,
è sempre stato attento a dire
ma non è che l'infanzia è così importante,
sono tutte balle.
Anche lì, arrivato in America,
in anni in cui Freud, evidentemente, dominava, no?
No, Brodsky ha sempre detto,
ma figuriamoci,
non contano niente queste cose.
In generale,
la vita materiale,
le circostanze esterne,
non contano niente.
Una volta che hai scoperto
che l'unica cosa che conta
è la vita interiore.
Su questa cosa lui tiene duro
arrivando a dire delle cose
che ti fanno, come dire,
avere qualche dubbio.
Ricevere un brutto voto a scuola,
far funzionare una fresa in fabbrica,
essere picchiato dalla polizia
durante un interrogatorio,
ottenere una lezione su Callimaco
in un'aula universitaria,
tutte cose che lui ha fatto in vita sua,
è essenzialmente la stessa cosa.
Perché quello che succede al di fuori
non conta niente,
il tuo io se ne sta dentro
la conchiglia
e guarda fuori le cose che succedono.
Oggi sarebbe come minimo
un BES nella nostra scuola
e magari anche una bella diagnosi di autismo.
Ecco,
e anche in Unione Sovietica
a un certo punto
rischierà di passare per squilibrato.
Ma questo è un altro discorso,
non anticipiamo.
Oltre all'odio per la scuola
e per la propaganda di regime,
per le bugie di regime,
c'è un'altra cosa
che aggiunge rabbia
ai suoi ricordi di infanzia
ed è l'antisemitismo di quegli anni.
Brodsky è un ebreo russo,
figlio di ebrei russi
completamente laici,
il papà è un ufficiale
della Marina Sovietica,
non ha avuto la minima educazione religiosa,
e però da ragazzino
si accorge di qualcosa.
Qui è importante sottolinearlo.
A volte si rischia di avere
un'immagine, come dire,
stereotipata del regime sovietico
come un regime antisemita.
Attenzione, bisogna andare a vedere,
a seconda dei momenti.
Perché la rivoluzione d'ottobre
è stata sposata con entusiasmo
dagli ebrei in Russia
e tanti dei capi bolshevichi
erano ebrei
e ancora sotto Stalin
negli anni trenta
molti quadri del regime sono ebrei.
Molti quadri del regime,
molti quadri della polizia politica,
molti picchiatori e torturatori
della Lubianca
e dirigenti dei lager
fino alla seconda guerra mondiale
sono ebrei.
E poi invece,
dopo la fine della seconda guerra mondiale,
il regime staliniano,
come se non bastasse tutto il resto,
prende anche una deriva antisemita.
E l'antisemitismo,
da sempre presente in Russia,
anziché essere combattuto e represso,
diventa una cosa
che il governo tutto sommato
incoraggia.
Ecco.
Negli ultimi anni di Stalin
la spinta antisemita
è talmente forte
che tra gli ebrei russi
comincia a diffondersi il timore
che un bel giorno
arrivi l'ordine di deportarli tutti
verso l'Asia centrale.
Brolsky dice
i miei un po' se l'aspettavano.
Hanno venduto il pianoforte
che avevamo in casa,
perché nella stanza e mezzo
avevano anche il pianoforte,
ma l'hanno venduto
dicendosi se si deportano
tanto mica possiamo portarcelo dietro.
E dice Brolsky
tanto io non ho mai imparato
a suonarlo,
ero completamente negato.
E nel 1950
il papà è congedato
dalla marina militare,
perché adesso
oltre un certo grado
gli ebrei
non li promuovono più.
E per un po'
fa fatica
a ritrovare un lavoro fisso.
Lui di mestiere
fa il fotografo.
È stato fotografo di guerra, appunto.
Per un po'
sono costretti a vivere
con lo stipendio della madre.
E sono anni
che Brolsky ricorda
come anni davvero di povertà.
Lui aveva dieci anni,
undici anni.
Poi grazie a un ex collega,
ebreo anche lui,
ma con un cognome
molto russo
e che quindi
non è stato licenziato,
il papà viene assunto
come giornalista
e fotoreporter
in un giornale
della marina mercantile
e ha di nuovo un lavoro.
La famiglia ricomincia a vivere.
La mamma dice,
entro in questi dettagli
perché
anche se non fosse Brodsky,
chiunque fosse,
vedere
nel concreto
cosa voleva dire
vivere
in quell'epoca
e in quel paese.
La mamma dice,
Brodsky,
non ha mai avuto problemi
perché era ebrea
anche lei,
però era una bionda
baltica
con gli occhi azzurri.
Mio papà invece
aveva un gran naso a becco,
dice Brodsky,
si vedeva subito
che era ebreo.
Io ho ereditato
il naso di mia madre
e lei era molto contenta.
La mamma sa il francese
perché è figlia di Borghesi,
ha avuto una buona educazione
prima della rivoluzione
e sa anche il tedesco
perché è nata
nei paesi baltici
e alla fine della guerra
la mamma lavora
come interprete
in un campo
di prigionieri di guerra
tedeschi,
tanto che ha il grado
di sottotenente
del ministero dell'interno
che è, come dire,
della polizia politica
e siccome è molto in gamba
le offrono anche
di fare carriera
nella polizia politica
però dovrebbe iscriversi
al partito
e lei non ha voglia
quindi lascia perdere
e torna a fare l'impiegata.
Con questo fatto
dell'antisemitismo
che monta
nell'Unione Sovietica
dei tardi anni 40
si collega
un ricordo di Brodsky
sulla prima bugia
che ha detto in vita sua
almeno la prima
che si ricorda
di aver detto.
La vera storia
della coscienza
comincia con la prima bugia.
Sida il caso
che io ricordi la mia.
Fu in una biblioteca
scolastica
e io dovevo compilare
la domanda
di iscrizione.
Sopra la quinta casella
stava scritto
naturalmente
nazionalità.
Avevo sette anni
e sapevo benissimo
di essere ebreo
ma dissi all'impiegata
che non sapevo
lei con un entusiasmo
di dubbio gusto
mi suggerì
di andare a casa
a chiedere
ai miei genitori.
In quella biblioteca
non tornai più
anche se mi iscrissi
a molte altre
che usavano
gli stessi moduli
di iscrizione.
Detto questo
Brodsky è sempre
stato attento a dire
ma sì vabbè
però l'antisemitismo
a noi non è capitato
niente
non capitava niente
da bambino
a scuola
i compagni
niente
a sette anni
dice
si è troppo piccoli
per essere
dei buoni antisemiti
e dice anche
e poi a quell'età
contano i pugni
e io me la cavavo
mica male
le battute antisemite
le facevano
gli insegnanti
però anche lì
Brodsky dice
ma di tanto
gli insegnanti
ci facevano
talmente tanta paura
e li odiavo
talmente tanto
che le battute antisemite
facevano
soltanto parte
del corredo
e poi c'erano anche
insegnanti ebrei
e io avevo paura
anche di loro
come di tutti gli altri
in effetti
Brodsky poi più tardi
quando in America
lo interrogeranno
su questo
rifiuterà sempre
qualunque atteggiamento
da perseguitato
e anzi
siccome era
vabbè
in piemontese
diremmo
un bastian contrario
uno che comunque
se gli dico
ma è così vero
la sua prima tendenza
di no
non è affatto così
non ha capito niente
in America
dirà sempre
ma sì
essere ebreo
cosa vuoi che conti
durante un'intervista
nel 79
in America
l'intervistatore
gli dice
lo sai
che all'università
di Boston
sei nella lista
delle letture
di un corso
che si intitola
scrittori ebrei
moderni
va bene
congratulazioni
all'università
di Boston
bravi
non so che dire
io sono un pessimo
ebreo
gli ambienti ebraici
mi hanno spesso accusato
di non sostenere
la causa
e di citare
troppo spesso
il nuovo testamento
compari anche
in un libro
che si intitola
ebrei famosi
oh mio Dio
perfetto
ebrei famosi
quindi sono
un ebreo famoso
d'ora in poi
mi presenterò così
faccio notare
che Brodsky
poteva essere
molto antipatico
quando voleva
non esitava
non si faceva
problemi di sorta
e da ragazzo
era un ragazzo difficile
appunto
un bambino
che faceva pipì a letto
senza amici
da ragazzo
mi sentivo
totalmente solo
leggevo libri
non avevo amici
né amiche
e siccome odia
la scuola
a 15 anni
decide di mollarla
di punto in bianco
non aspetta neanche
la fine dell'anno
un bel giorno esce
e non ci torna più
in seguito dirà
a quell'epoca
mi ero raccontato
una bugia
che in casa
servivano soldi
che serviva il mio aiuto
dovevo andare a lavorare
ma in realtà
i miei avrebbero preferito
che continuassi
ad andare a scuola
ma io mi sono raccontato
quella bugia
perché in realtà
volevo tagliare
la corda
e da allora
non ho fatto altro
che tagliare la corda
sempre più spesso
quindi va a lavorare
per prima cosa
trova lavoro in fabbrica
alla fresa
a 15 anni
lavora come fresatore
in fabbrica
dirà
è stata un'esperienza fondamentale
lì ho conosciuto
il vero proletariato
anche in Russia
il proletariato
alla fine degli anni 50
si è imborghesito
ma negli anni 50
erano ancora i proletari veri
che vivevano
in stanze sovraffollate
bevevano come spugne
picchiavano la moglie
erano pronti
a mettersi a piangere
al cinema
a un film sentimentale
oppure alla morte di Stalin
lì anche la prima
come dire
consapevolezza
di come funziona
il regime sovietico
in fabbrica
non lavorava nessuno
ma specialmente
il lunedì mattina
perché si erano tutti ubriacati
e in particolare
la produzione segnava
un brusco ribasso
dopo una sconfitta
della squadra di calcio
locale o nazionale
nessuno lavorava
tutti discutevano
i particolari dell'incontro
e i giocatori
perché la Russia
insieme a tutti i complessi
di una nazione superiore
ha il grande complesso
di inferiorità
di un piccolo paese
dopo un anno
lascia la fabbrica
si mette in testa
di provare a studiare medicina
per cominciare
trova lavoro
come aiutante
nell'obitorio
di un ospedale
per un po'
assiste alle autopsie
poi scopre
che non gli piace
se ne va
fa il fuochista
su una nave
il guardiano
di un faro
finalmente
a 18 anni
scopre il lavoro
che non gli dispiace
troppo
le spedizioni
geologiche
di cosa si tratta?
l'Unione Sovietica
è un paese immenso
pieno di risorse
minerarie inesplorate
dal circolo polare
artico
fino ai deserti
dell'Asia centrale
in Unione Sovietica
quindi c'era
un enorme lavoro
di geologia
innumerevoli missioni
che venivano mandate
ai quattro angoli
del paese
a scavare
e a fare perizie
e Brodsky scopre
che si può unirsi
a queste spedizioni
come aiuto
star via
per qualche mese
viaggiare
in quel modo
riuscì a vedere
terre lontanissime
a spese
del governo
incontrando
tante persone
la geologia
allora
da qualche parte
dice la geologia
è anche un'altra cosa
l'archeologia
era l'approdo
di tanti giovani
che soffrivano
per la mancanza
di libertà
si poteva viaggiare
e cosa vuoi di più
a quell'età
certo
non era consentito
andare all'estero
ma la Russia
è così grande
e poi dice
pagare pagavano male
però non c'erano spese
alla fine della missione
ti trovavi tutto
il salario pronto
tornavi a casa
io tornavo a casa
per qualche mese
ci vivevo
verso Natale
o Capodanno
finivo i soldi
e a quel punto
iniziavo a cercare
un altro lavoro
in questo modo
visita alcune
tra le regioni
più sperdute
dell'Unione Sovietica
e
più tardi
più tardi dirà
quando mi hanno arrestato
la prima volta
mi hanno detto
guarda che ti spediamo
molto lontano
ma i posti
che citavano
io c'ero già stato
ma perché
l'hanno arrestato
la prima volta
il punto è questo
adesso
il punto è
l'attrito
col sistema
con un sistema
in cui da un lato
il ragazzino
che da bambino
adorava i cappotti neri
della Marina Sovietica
il ragazzino
ha smesso di credere
molto presto
il suo primo ricordo politico
è la morte di Stalin
nel 1953
lui ha 13 anni
sentite come lo racconta
della morte di Stalin
ho un ricordo
piuttosto nitido
ero già in seconda
o terza media
la scolaresca
venne condotta
nell'aulamagna
e la segretaria
del partito
presso la scuola
una vecchia fedele
che in quell'occasione
sfoggiava
tutte le sue decorazioni
salì sul podio
iniziò a parlarci
della morte di Stalin
e arrivata
a metà della frase
con voce rotta
cominciò a gridare
in ginocchio
la maggior parte
di noi
si inginocchiò
e tutti
iniziarono a piangere
o a fingere
di piangere
come fanno i bambini
l'unica cosa
di cui posso
vantarmi
è che non riuscì
a trovare motivi validi
per disperarmi
poi ci lasciarono
andare a casa
tornai
nell'appartamento
che condividevamo
con un'altra famiglia
e in cucina
vidi le donne
con gli occhi
arrossati
che piangevano
ancora
anche mia madre
piangeva
turbato
tornai
nella mia stanza
papà era seduto
al tavolo
da pranzo
gli chiesi
che succede
lui mi guardò
e mi strizzò
l'occhio
e questo evidentemente
a 13 anni
è stata una
di quelle esperienze
insomma
che uno poi
si ricorda
così come ricorda
poi il 56
l'insurrezione
anticomunista
in Ungheria
e l'intervento
sovietico
per soffocare
l'insurrezione
quando dice
è il momento
in cui
definitivamente
ho smesso
di credere
che il regime
potesse avere
qualche futuro
notate che Brodsky
non ha mai preteso
di essere un dissidente
non ha mai fatto
militanza
contro il regime
il regime
gli faceva schifo
ma la politica
non gli interessava
minimamente
e lui ha sempre pensato
che fosse il suo diritto
dire a me
della politica
non mi importa
niente
nelle sue interviste
in America
quando gli parlano
di questo
lui rivendica
la sua indifferenza
con quella
che a noi
può anche sembrare
appunto
arroganza
non sono mai caduto
così in basso
da urlare
a basso
il regime sovietico
lo ignori
e te ne stai chiuso
dentro la tua conchiglia
e tiri fuori
la tua poesia
di tutto il resto
non ti frega niente
e mentre passa
da un lavoro
all'altro
nei momenti liberi
nei lunghi mesi
in cui riesce a vivere
senza lavorare
legge
legge furiosamente
tutto quello
che riesce a trovare
impara da solo
l'inglese
e il polacco
per leggere
i poeti
e in quel momento
decide una volta
per tutte
che i libri
e la poesia
sono la cosa
più importante
del mondo
e per la prima volta
scopre degli amici
perché ci sono
altri ragazzi
della sua generazione
che hanno
lo stesso rifiuto
del mondo
intorno a loro
e la stessa voglia
di vivere
per i libri
e per la poesia
infatti
dei ricordi
a questo punto
comincia a parlare
al plurale
eravamo lettori
insaziabili
e quello che leggevamo
creava in noi
uno stato
di dipendenza
di assuefazione
i libri
ci tenevano
in loro potere
dice anche
i libri
sostituivano
le persone
che scarseggiavano
a quei tempi
nella Russia
del dopoguerra
era raro
avere fratelli
o sorelle
erano rari
i padri
per lo più morti
in guerra
noi cercavamo
i nostri parenti
nei libri
personaggi
come Davide Copperfield
o Mitya Karamazov
erano per noi
più reali
di qualunque altro
poi però
dirà anche
sempre ragionandoci
in seguito
su questi anni
giovanili
dirà anche
in realtà
tuffarsi nei libri
era l'unico modo
per fare quello
che volevi tu
e non quello
che volevano
farti fare
gli altri
allora
la letteratura
il cinema
la scrittura
e forse
l'adulterio
erano le uniche forme
di libera iniziativa
quel che facevi
dipendeva
da te
ma questo
era precisamente
quello che il potere
sovietico
non poteva permettere
cioè che qualcuno
pretendesse di vivere
per se stesso
ignorando
la collettività
la società
lo Stato
e per di più
esponendo pubblicamente
con le proprie poesie
questo proprio
atteggiamento
appena le prime poesie
di Brodsky
cominciano a circolare
e non sono poesie
politiche
non sono poesie
contro il regime
ma sono poesie
che esprimono
questo punto di vista
di estremo
individualismo
il Kagebe
apre un fascicolo
e comincia
a tenerlo
d'occhio
e quando lo arresteranno
non si stupirà
perché sapevo
che stavo facendo
le cose a modo mio
qualcosa
che in sostanza
equivale
a un'impresa privata
all'interno
di un sistema
controllato
dallo Stato
e sapevo
che da un giorno
all'altro
mi avrebbero beccato
oh io non mi voglio
fermare troppo
su questo
però non posso
non sottolineare
che Brodsky
è
un individualista
è un poeta
convinto
che la poesia
è l'unica cosa
che conta al mondo
e tutto il resto
non conta niente
a un livello tale
che
come dire
anche oggi
nel nostro mondo
farebbe fatica
a far accettare
il suo atteggiamento
quando arriva in America
è pieno di illusioni
crede che gli americani
siano individualisti
quanto lui
rimane molto deluso
non è affatto
un paese così libero
di fare quel che si vuole
come io credevo
ed è uno capace
di dire cose
che oggi
non oso pensare
sui social
se un personaggio
così in vista
come lui
una volta arrivato
in America
dicesse
un dissidente
io
qualsiasi tipo
di impegno civile
semplicemente
mi annoia a morte
e
quanto alla poesia
la poesia
è la forma
più alta
dell'attività
umana
è il fine
dell'esistenza
dell'umanità
è l'unico modo
con cui possiamo
conoscere
veramente
la realtà
cito
di per sé
la realtà
non vale un accidente
è il modo
in cui la percepiamo
che le dà dignità
è l'unico modo
elevato
di percepirle
attraverso
la poesia
è
per dirla
fino in fondo
la meta
della nostra
specie
c'è un'intervista
in cui
l'intervistatrice
americana
gli chiede
qual è secondo lei
il compito
dell'artista
sembra di vederlo
che alza gli occhi
al cielo
e gli dici
compito
dell'artista
ma stiamo parlando
di poeti
scrivere bene
basta
ancora
ai nostri giorni
è piuttosto diffusa
l'idea
che uno scrittore
in particolare
un poeta
debba usare
nella sua opera
la lingua
della strada
della folla
nonostante
la sua apparente
democraticità
questa pretesa
è semplicemente
assurda
se l'homo sapiens
dovesse fermarsi
nella sua evoluzione
allora va bene
la letteratura
potrà parlare
la lingua del popolo
in caso contrario
sarà piuttosto
il popolo
a dover parlare
la lingua
della letteratura
ancora
un'esistenza
che ignora
i criteri
proposti
dalla letteratura
è un'esistenza
inferiore
se a questo punto
si levano
grida
di vigliacco
elitista
e magari
si levano
guarda un po'
proprio in certe
università occidentali
sarà bene
infischiarsene
perché la cultura
è elitista
per definizione
allora potete
immaginare
visto che vi vedo
tutti quanti
attoniti
giustamente
potete immaginare
dell'unione sovietica
del 1960
che bella impressione
poteva fare
un ragazzino
presuntuoso
un ebreo
con i capelli rossi
che arrivava lì
a dire queste cose
e infatti
quando Brodsky
comincia a presentarsi
in pubblico
come poeta
si capisce subito
che avrà
dei grossi fastidi
la sua prima uscita
pubblica
è il 14 febbraio
a vent'anni
quando partecipa
al torneo
dei poeti
nel palazzo
della cultura
di Leningrado
e si esibisce
con la lettura
della sua poesia
cimitero ebreo
vicino
a Leningrado
ora
questa poesia
io ve la leggo
è una poesia
scritta
dal ragazzino
a 18 anni
non è un granché
come poesia
intendiamoci
Brodsky
ragazzino
come tutti i ragazzini
che cominciano
a scrivere poesie
credeva
di poter scrivere
poesie
senza la rima
in verso libero
molto presto
rinsavirà
tutta la grande
poesia di Brodsky
come tutta la grande
poesia russa
è tutta sempre
esclusivamente
in rima
e in metrica
molto rigorosa
all'inizio invece
appunto
vittima un po'
degli umori
del momento
scrive poesie
come questa
ve la leggo
per provate a immaginare
siamo nel 1960
a Leningrado
in pubblico
arriva un ragazzino
di vent'anni
ebreo
per giunta
e legge
questa poesia
cimitero ebraico
vicino a Leningrado
uno steccato
storto
fatto di compensato
dietro uno steccato
storto
giacciono
fianco a fianco
giuristi
commercianti
suonatori
rivoluzionari
hanno cantato
per se stessi
hanno accumulato
soldi
per se stessi
per gli altri
sono morti
ma all'inizio
pagavano le tasse
rispettavano
l'ufficiale
giudiziario
e in questo mondo
prigioniero
del materialismo
interpretavano
il Talmud
restavano
idealisti
forse vedevano
più lontano
o magari
credevano
ciecamente
ma insegnavano
ai bambini
a essere pazienti
e non seminavano
il pane
non hanno mai
seminato
il pane
solo
si sono
coricati
loro stessi
nella terra
fredda
come semi
e si sono
addormentati
per sempre
e poi
li hanno coperti
di terra
gli hanno
acceso
candele
e nel giorno
del ricordo
i vecchi
affamati
con voci
acute
senza fiato
per la fame
hanno urlato
chiedendo pace
e l'hanno
ottenuta
sotto forma
della decomposizione
della materia
senza ricordare
niente
senza
dimenticare
niente
dietro
a uno steccato
storto
fatto di
compensato
a quattro chilometri
dal capolinea
del tram
il pubblico
nel suo insieme
non reagisce
dicono le cronache
mica tanto male
a questa poesia
ma i poeti
presenti
insorgono
i poeti
più autorevoli
presenti alla lettura
cominciano a gridare
cacciate via
quel teppista
il fatto che il tema
sia ebraico
non è neanche così importante
fra i poeti
che urlano
di cacciare via
c'è anche un ebreo
che poi nel 67
se ne andrà in Israele
il punto è
la sfida
al materialismo
sono rimasti
idealisti
in un mondo
acciecato
dal materialismo
mentre il Kagebe
comincia a prendere appunti
i giovani poeti
di Leningrado
lo identificano
come uno dei loro
anzi
come il capofino
e gli fanno conoscere
per chi c'era ieri
Anna Akhmatova
che ha i suoi ultimi anni
di vita
è ammirata
follemente
da tutti questi
giovani poeti
di Leningrado
e Brodsky
è quello che lei
individua
come quello
più bravo
di tutti
gli altri del gruppo
dicono
lei se ne è accorta
già allora
che lui era
di un'altra categoria
noi non ce ne eravamo
ancora accorti
ma Anna
se ne è accorta
sì
con tutto questo
naturalmente
il bambino
che faceva pipì
a letto
continua a avere
dei problemi
di salute
anche mentale
soffre di fobie
soffre di balbuzie
continua a partecipare
alle spedizioni
geologiche
ma nel 61
durante una spedizione
in estremo oriente
ha un collasso nervoso
lo rimpatriano
Leningrado
lo mettono
sotto osservazione
in clinica
psichiatrica
se non altro
gli va bene
la commissione
di leva
dell'esercito
lo dichiara
inabile
al servizio militare
non partecipa
più alle spedizioni
geologiche
non regge
psicologicamente
deve trovarsi
un altro lavoro
cosa sa fare
versi
non glieli pubblicano
si mette a fare
traduzioni
gliene danno
pubblica
traduzioni
guadagna
guadagna anche
abbastanza bene
finché un bel giorno
è il 29 novembre
del 63
sul giornale
Viecerni Leningrad
Leningrado Sera
esce un articolo
che si intitola
Un fannullone letterato
in cui si parla
di questo giovanotto
di Pietroburgo
di Leningrado
scusatemi
che scrive
queste poesie
così
che non sono sovietiche
per niente
decadenti
formaliste
quel che è peggio
uno che non lavora
un giovanotto sano
di 26 anni
che da circa
4 anni
non lavora
questo articolo
è un segnale
chiarissimo
vuol dire
che deve aspettarsi
dei guai
tant'è vero
che gli amici
lo convincono
a farsi ricoverare
un'altra volta
in clinica
per vedere
se gli danno
una bella diagnosi
di disturbi psichici
che lo metta
al sicuro
da eventuali
persecuzioni
Brodsky va
in clinica
per la seconda
volta
però si spaventa
gli fanno
strane iniezioni
e dopo un po'
gli sembra
di perdere la ragione
se ne va
si porta dietro
una diagnosi
di psicopatia
schizoide
e pochi giorni dopo
cerca di suicidarsi
tagliandosi le vene
non c'entrano niente
né la clinica
psichiatrica
né la persecuzione
il punto è
che
da un anno
e più
ha cominciato
una storia
d'amore
tremenda
con Marianna
Marianna Pavlovna
Basmanova
una giovane pittrice
a cui dedica
molte delle sue poesie
per tutta la vita
e anche dopo
che l'ha lasciata
per sempre
e questo amore
è un amore
terribilmente infelice
anzi proprio
in quel momento
quando si addensa
la persecuzione
su di lui
lui poi dirà
ma io non me ne accorgevo
neanche
il tutto coincideva
con il mio più grande
dramma personale
per via di una ragazza
eccetera
lui non è mai entrato
nei dettagli
fatto sta che
mentre lui cerca di ammazzarsi
perché Marianna
in realtà
l'ha mollato
esce un altro articolo
sul giornale
è l'8 gennaio del 64
stavolta non è un articolo
di un giornalista
è una raccolta
di lettere al giornale
i lettori scrivono
al giornale dicendo
bisogna finirla
con questo scandalo
con questo parassita
con questo giovanotto
che si permette
di non lavorare
quando è che la facciamo finita
è una regia chiarissima
queste cose succedevano così
anche vent'anni prima
sotto Stalin
il 13 gennaio del 64
Brodsky viene arrestato
a 24 anni
e il 18 febbraio
è processato
per parassitismo
il processo
di Brodsky
è un momento
di grande importanza
storica
non soltanto
per la sua vicenda
ma perché più in generale
ha delle ricadute
sul movimento
della dissidenza
in Unione Sovietica
ma anche
sull'attenzione internazionale
verso
l'Unione Sovietica
ecco
delle ricadute
assolutamente impreviste
tenete conto
della situazione
l'Unione Sovietica
sta uscendo
dai brevi anni
del disgelo
da quei pochi anni
dopo il rapporto
Khrushchev
la denuncia
dei crimini di Stalin
la liquidazione
dei lager
pochi anni
in cui anche
la censura
era stata allentata
hanno pubblicato
Solzhenitsyn
una giornata
di Ivan Denisovic
il racconto
che parla appunto
della vita
nei lager di Stalin
pochi anni
di apparente libertà
in quel momento
sta ritornando
un clima
più repressivo
e il potere
decide di dare
un esempio
Brodsky
ha 24 anni
è un poeta
ormai
abbastanza famoso
perché valga
la pena
di sceglierlo
per dare
un esempio
in modo che
tutti capiscano
è processato
dicevamo
e vi siete messi a ridere
giustamente
per parassitismo
allora
bisogna sapere
come funziona
quel mondo
l'Unione Sovietica
è un paese
meraviglioso
dove è vietato
non lavorare
lavoro c'è per tutti
basta che lo chiedi
ovviamente
se vuoi fare
il chirurgo
ma se vai
in qualunque fabbrica
e vuoi entrare
alla linea di montaggio
ti assumono
qualunque fabbrica
assume chiunque
perché funziona così
il direttore
ha mille operai
gli danno lo stipendio
per mille operai
ne ha duemila
e gli danno lo stipendio
per duemila
tutti lavorano
e non lavorare
è un reato
c'è un decreto
apposta
ma il punto
è che il decreto
contro i parassiti
è un decreto
che è stato concepito
in realtà
per colpire
come dire
i delinquenti
abituali
chi vive
di prostituzione
di gioco d'azzardo
anche in Unione Sovietica
c'era tutto questo
c'era tutto
in Unione Sovietica
ovviamente
e il decreto
è stato concepito
per permettere
alle autorità
di colpire persone
di questo genere
il caso Brodsky
è il primo esempio
dell'uso di questo decreto
per colpire invece
un intellettuale
sgradito
e gli storici
oggi ne parlano
come appunto
un momento di svolta
un esperimento
le autorità
hanno provato
a vedere
cosa succedeva
se usando
quel decreto
quel tipo
di accusa
si riusciva
a intimidire
e rendere inoffensivo
un intellettuale
sgradito
noi abbiamo
i verbali
del processo
sono stati pubblicati
ma già all'epoca
durante il processo
c'era
una giornalista
che prendeva appunti
non autorizzata
il giudice
o meglio
la giudice
perché è una donna
il giudice
Savieleva
la giudice
più volte
nei verbali
dice
lei cosa fa lì
sta prendendo appunti
è vietato
in qualche modo
questa continua
a prendere appunti
lo stesso
li porta fuori
arrivano anche all'estero
il processo Brodsky
a un certo punto
viene seguito
all'estero
la BBC
trasmette i verbali
e i verbali
di questo
di questo dibattito
sono
straordinari
il punto centrale
ovviamente
è che Brodsky
dice
io lavoro
faccio il poeta
faccio il traduttore
mentre il giudice
vuole dimostrare
che lui non lavora
quindi
giudice
ma in generale
qual è la sua professione
poeta
poeta e traduttore
e chi ha dichiarato
che siete poeta
chi è che vi ha incluso
fra i poeti
nessuno
e chi mi ha incluso
nel genere umano
ma voi
avete studiato
per questo
per cosa
per essere un poeta
non avete cercato
di completare
l'istituto
dove preparano
dove insegnano
io non pensavo
che fosse una cosa
che si insegna
e come si diventa
poeta allora
io penso
che sia un dono
di Dio
poi ancora il giudice
avete richieste
da presentare
al tribunale
vorrei sapere
perché mi hanno arrestato
questa è una domanda
non una richiesta
allora
non richiesta
l'avvocato di Brodsky
che è una donna
anche lei
Taporova
porta le prove
i suoi lavori
di traduttore
però siccome ci crede poco
e ha capito
l'aria che tira
in realtà
cerca di sostenere
che sono i problemi psichici
che gli impediscono
di lavorare
in modo continuativo
e chiede
una perizia medica
il tribunale decide
una perizia psichiatrica
in realtà
non allo scopo
di vedere
se lui
può essere considerato
innocente
ma allo scopo
di vedere
se posso portare
una condanna
ordinano
la perizia psichiatrica
finita l'udienza
escono
all'uscita
dell'aula
si rendono conto
che c'è un'enorme
folla fuori
la giudice
quanta gente
non pensavo
ci sarebbe stato
un afflusso così
una voce
tra la folla
non accade
tutti i giorni
che si processi
un poeta
la giudice
poeta o no
per noi
è la stessa cosa
tre settimane
in clinica psichiatrica
e stavolta
senza
il diritto
di andarsene
quando non gli piace più
ricordi drammatici
lo svegliere
in piena notte
gli fanno bagni freddi
alla fine
arriva la perizia
che conclude
che il soggetto
presenta
tratti patologici
ma è idoneo
al lavoro
e quindi
può essere
condannato
all'obbligo
di lavorare
e qualche giorno
dopo
c'è la seconda
seduta
vi leggo anche qui
un po' di questo
verbale
che trovo appunto
una fonte
straordinaria
la giudice
cittadino
Brodsky
dal 1956
voi avete cambiato
impiego
13 volte
avete lavorato
un anno in fabbrica
poi avete smesso
di lavorare
per sei mesi
avete partecipato
a una spedizione
geologica
poi restate
quattro mesi
senza lavorare
spiegate
alla corte
perché durante
questi intervalli
avete vissuto
da parassita
Brodsky
durante questi intervalli
ho lavorato
ho scritto versi
dunque avete scritto
i vostri
cosiddetti versi
ma cosa avete fatto
di utile
per la patria
ho scritto poesie
questo è il mio lavoro
e credo fermamente
che quel che ho scritto
sarà utile
non solo
alla gente di oggi
ma alle generazioni
future
voce dal pubblico
guarda un po'
si dà delle arie
altra voce
è un poeta
è normale
che pensi così
la giudice
allora voi pensate
che i vostri
cosiddetti versi
portino qualche vantaggio
alla gente
Brodsky
ma perché dite
sempre cosiddetti
i vostri versi
li chiamiamo cosiddetti
perché non riusciamo
a capirli
in un altro modo
e poi vengono i testimoni
la sto facendo troppo lunga
vabbè pazienza
resterete un po' di più
stasera
la difesa chiama diversi poeti
e traduttori
anche gente importante
che ha degli incarichi
direzionali
e tutti dichiarano
che la poesia di Brodsky
è lavoro
che le traduzioni di Brodsky
sono un lavoro
importante
di altissimo livello
che è un ragazzo
di grande avvenire
c'è una poetessa
Natalia Grudignina
che è anche un boss
dell'unione degli scrittori
una che organizza
gruppi di lavoro
di giovani letterati
e dichiara
io
io penso che abbia
molto talento
e la giudice
e perché lavora da solo
perché non frequenta
nessuna associazione letteraria
e la Grudignina
nel 58
ha chiesto
di essere ammesso
nel mio gruppo
ho rifiutato
perché avevo sentito
parlare di lui
come di un giovane isterico
sono personalmente
responsabile
di averlo respinto
è stato un errore
di cui mi pento molto
fra i poeti
chiamati a testimoniare
due sono ebrei
e con tutti e due
la giudice
fa la stessa
ignobile sceneggiata
cioè li chiama
e poi dice
ah
il suo cognome è insolito
posso vedere il suo documento
sta di fatto
che di questi testimoni
a favore di Brodsky
tutte persone importanti
del mondo culturale
più di uno
poi avrà dei fastidi
sul lavoro
per essere venuto
a testimoniare
in suo favore
trasferimenti
ammunizioni
l'accusa invece
porta come testimoni
dei militari
degli operai
dei pensionati
nessuno dei quali
conosce Brodsky
ma tutti hanno sentito
parlare di lui
e del pessimo
influsso che ha
sui giovani
Smirnoff
un militare
con gente così
non costruiremo mai
il comunismo
è andato solo
sette anni a scuola
chiedo ai presenti
vorreste che i vostri figli
andassero a scuola
solo sette anni
e come mai
non ha fatto il militare
siamo sicuri
di quel certificato medico
Logunov
dirigente del museo
Hermitage
vivere come vive
Brodsky
da noi
non è più possibile
compiango i suoi genitori
Brodsky
deve ricominciare
la sua vita
da zero
Nikolaev
pensionato
non conosco
personalmente
Brodsky
ma sono al corrente
dell'influenza
disastrosa
che esercita
sui suoi coetanei
sono padre
di famiglia
e so per esperienza
quanto è duro
avere un figlio
come lui
che non lavora
più di una volta
ho trovato
da mio figlio
delle poesie
di Brodsky
ora ascoltandolo
ho riconosciuto
mio figlio
anche lui
si considera
un genio
anche lui
si rifiuta
di lavorare
è evidente
che questo qua
sa fare dei versi
ma i suoi versi
fanno del male
Brodsky
non è un semplice
parassita
è un parassita
militante
e con gente
come lui
bisogna essere
senza pietà
il 13 marzo
del 64
Brodsky
è condannato
al massimo
della pena
prevista
per il reato
di parassitismo
5 anni
di lavoro
obbligatorio
in località
remota
non è una condanna
al lagere
sia chiaro
Brodsky
non è mai stato
in campo
in vita sua
gli stalinisti
stanno rialzando
la testa
ma il paese
e l'epoca
sono molto diversi
non si può più
mandare la gente
nel lagere
così facilmente
diciamo
la definizione migliore
in italiano
sarebbe
confino
con obbligo
di trovarsi
un lavoro
Anna Akhmatova
che ne aveva viste
ben altre
fa un commento
che può sembrare
cinico
e che invece
è molto appropriato
ricordiamoci che
Brodsky ha i capelli rossi
Anna Akhmatova
che biografia
che fabbricano
al nostro rosso
neanche li avesse
assunti
apposta
e infatti
io sono qua
che sto riempiendo
metà della mia lezione
raccontandovi
dunque
lo trasferiscono
nell'estremo nord
in un piccolissimo
villaggio
dove viene assunto
nella fattoria
collettiva
locale
è un posto
in capo al mondo
Brodsky poi dirà
minacciavano sempre
di mandarmi in posti
molto lontani
quando alla fine
in uno di quei posti
mi ci hanno mandato
è venuto fuori
che era una zona
che conoscevo
piuttosto bene
oh ve l'ho detto
che un bastian contrario
in America
gli chiederanno
della tragedia
della deportazione
ha sempre risposto
gli anni migliori
della mia vita
i due anni
trascorsi in campagna
sono stati
uno dei periodi
più belli
della mia vita
sono riuscito
a scrivere lì
più che in ogni
altro posto
sì
dovevo lavorare
di giorno
ma si trattava
di lavoro agricolo
non era come
essere in fabbrica
avevamo lunghi periodi
in cui non c'era
niente da fare
gli amici
gli mandano i libri
riceve i poeti inglesi
Oder
legge
traduce
scrive
lo lasciamo tornare
quattro volte
in permesso
a Leningrado
dove ritrova
Marianna
che si è pentita
si rimettono insieme
a distanza
al confino
pubblica
per filo
delle poesie
su una rivista locale
l'Unione Sovietica
è grande
lì nessuno sa
chi sia lui
a Leningrado
non lo pubblicherebbero mai
lì lo pubblicano
e intanto
siccome appunto
questo è un paese
ancora un paese
surreale
tremendo
ma non è più
il paese di Stalin
in Unione Sovietica
cresce un movimento
di intellettuali
a favore di Brodsky
lo capeggia
Anna Akhmatova
scrivono a tutte
le autorità possibili
scrivono ai giornali
la cosa riecheggia
all'estero
e in un modo
o nell'altro
le autorità sovietiche
si scocciano
il fatto che anche
all'estero
si parla di questa condanna
gli intellettuali comunisti
in occidente
Sartre
per esempio
fanno sapere
che non è stata
una bella cosa
che l'Unione Sovietica
non ci guadagna niente
a fare queste cose
morale
alla fine
dopo un anno e mezzo
gli annullano la condanna
e lo rimandano
a Leningrado
e Brodsky
vivrà a Leningrado
ancora per sette anni
legale
adesso
gli danno un posto
nell'Unione degli scrittori
sezione traduzioni
lavora
traduce
pubblica
perfino poesie
poche
gliene pubblicano
ma il grosso circola
in quello che ormai
si chiama
il samisdat
le autoedizioni
gli amici
che battono a macchina
in tante copie
e distribuiscono
e tutti quelli
che le ricevono
battono a macchina
e distribuiscono
e alla fine
tutti leggono
queste poesie
oppure
si recitano
a voce alta
ci sono le cassette
all'epoca
ecco
Brodsky
abita sempre
a casa dei suoi
però
perché guadagna
troppo poco
per riuscire
ad andare a vivere
da solo
racconterà sempre
che era una grossa
scocciatura
perché con le ragazze
come fai
quando veniva
a trovarmi una ragazza
mettevo su un disco
di Bach
a volume altissimo
alla fine
i miei odiavano Bach
però insomma
vabbè
la ragazza poi
è Marianna
che a un certo punto
gli fa anche un figlio
però non sono sposati
il figlio
prende il nome
il cognome
di Marianna
non è mai stato
ben chiaro
quanto questo figlio
fosse voluto
Brodsky poi
della sua vita privata
in termini espliciti
ha sempre parlato
pochissimo
ne parla tanto
nella poesia
ma in modo
estremamente astratto
e poi
dopo questi sette anni
di intervallo
durante i quali
a New York
esce una sua raccolta
di poesie
tradotta in inglese
per cui ormai
è una celebrità
internazionale
nel 1972
succede un'altra cosa
surreale
dovete sapere
che dall'Unione Sovietica
era ovviamente
vietato andarsene
se non con un permesso
che si dava
a pochissimi
Brodsky
riceve spesso
dall'estero
inviti
per andare
a congressi
letture di poesia
università
non lo lasciano
mai andare
ma nei primi anni
settanta
nel clima di distensione
internazionale
l'Unione Sovietica
sta dando
il permesso
di emigrare
in Israele
a quei cittadini
ebrei
che vogliono
andarci
questo è il contesto
nel maggio
a casa di Brodsky
suona il telefono
e l'ufficio
visti
e gli dicono
senta
abbiamo bisogno
di parlarle
potrebbe mica
venire oggi
e Brodsky
dice ma oggi
oggi è veramente
per me un po' difficile
oggi
al massimo
stasera tardi
benissimo
venga venga
l'aspettiamo
vado
la sera
all'ufficio visti
mi riceve
un colonnello
gentilissimo
che mi dice
cittadino Brodsky
lei ha ricevuto
un invito
per andare
in Israele
e io che non avevo
capito
dice ha detto
anche
quando mi ha telefonato
l'ufficio visti
non capivo mica
ho pensato
magari ho qualche
parente all'estero
che mi ha lasciato
un'eredità
e Brodsky
continua a non capire
dice sì sì
ma io ne ricevo
di inviti
mica solo per Israele
dall'America
dall'Inghilterra
non mi avete mai
lasciato andare
no dice il colonnello
guardi
questo qua è proprio
un invito
per trasferirsi
in Israele
e Brodsky
dice ma io non voglio
andare in Israele
non ci ho mai pensato
in vita mia
a questo punto
dice il colonnello
ha cambiato tono
e mi fa
Brodsky
sarà meglio
che ci ripensi
o ci vai
o avrai
un momentino
difficile
e mi mette
sotto il naso
il modulo
per la richiesta
di espatrio
e lui lì
in quel momento
quella sera
su due piedi
deve decidere
cosa fare
e decide
di andarci
e compila
il modulo
sul modulo
c'è scritto
anche
quale parente
ha mandato
l'invito
dall'estero
è tutta una finzione
cosa devo scrivere
ma metta
una sorella
della madre
e il maggio
del 72
un mese dopo
Brodsky
è su un aereo
diretto a Vienna
ha lasciato
Marianna
che non vedrà
mai più
ha lasciato
il figlio
che quando sarà
adulto
lo vedrà
invece
il figlio
lascia i genitori
che non rivedrà
mai più
i genitori
poi tutti gli anni
faranno domanda
per poterlo andare
a trovare in America
non gli daranno
mai il permesso
parte
ufficialmente
per andare in Israele
in realtà
poi dirà sempre
io c'era una cosa
che sapevo
che non volevo
andare in Israele
ma amici americani
sono informati
vengono a prenderlo
a Vienna
gli hanno trovato
un'offerta di lavoro
in America
per insegnare poesia
all'università
del Michigan
nella città
di Ann Arbor
e un altro mese
due mesi dopo
l'intervista
con il colonnello
dell'ufficio Visti
Brodsky
è professore
all'università
del Michigan
e tiene un corso
di poesia
i racconti
su questo corso
sono leggendari
l'inglese
l'aveva imparato
da solo
parlava malissimo
in compenso
aveva letto
tutto quello
che si può leggere
arriva in America
rimane sterrefatto
da quella
che lui sembra
l'ignoranza
spaventosa
degli studenti
americani
siccome questi studenti
non sanno niente
non hanno mai letto niente
lui non ha mai
insegnato in vita sua
deve fare il corso
di poesia
e quindi
gli legge le poesie
l'intero corso
consiste nel fatto
che lui legge
poesie
a voce alta
e li costringe
a impararle
a memoria
quando uno studente
protesta
che lui non vuole
imparare poesia
a memoria
viene espulso
dal corso
molti anni dopo
tornerà
a Ann Arbor
invitato
alla festa
dei laureandi
e dirà
ma siamo ormai
nell'88
dirà
sì sì
tutto sommato
riconosco
l'odore
di Ann Arbor
anche se
devo dire
che oggi
c'è meno marijuana
nell'aria
di quanta ce ne fosse
negli anni 70
e questo
per un vecchio
abitué
crea un po'
di smarrimento
devo dire
ah sì
durante il corso
e alla fine del corso
gli studenti
devono fare
naturalmente
scrivere una loro poesia
e uno dei consigli
è
scrivete
come se fosse
l'ultima cosa
che scrivete
in vita vostra
tenete presente
che potreste
essere investiti
da un'auto
subito dopo averla consegnata
Brodsky vive
la seconda metà
della sua vita
in esilio
riflettendo molto
sulla tristezza
di chi
arriva da un paese
dittatoriale
può apprezzare
i vantaggi
della democrazia
molto meglio
di chi c'è nato
e al tempo stesso
si trova
si trova a disagio
perché vive in un mondo
che non funziona più
come quello
a cui lui era abituato
lui dice
una volta
eri sotto pressione
sotto una pressione
tremenda
adesso
quella pressione
di colpo
non c'è più
e l'io
si gonfia
a dismisura
non hai più niente
da fare
comincia a polemizzare
a vuoto
vai avanti
a interviste
e ancora
in Russia
era come se
la forza di gravità
fosse decuplicata
ogni gesto
ogni parola
costavano
molta fatica
ma avevano
ripercussioni enormi
in occidente
è come sulla luna
puoi anche saltare
super aria
non fai nessuno sforzo
ma non significa nulla
nessuno ti bada
guadagnerà anche
la consapevolezza
che la mostruosità
c'è dappertutto
mentre quando ero in Russia
pensavo che fosse
una nostra specialità locale
e però il vero problema
è
che in realtà
lui continua a pensare
al paese
che ha lasciato
continua a essere
ossessionato
dal paese
che ha lasciato
e una delle poesie
che a me piacciono di più
di Brodsky
è proprio una poesia
in cui prova a raccontare
che cos'era
quel paese
io adesso ve la leggo
è la seconda
è la più importante
poesia di Brodsky
che ho pensato di leggere
durante questa lezione
è molto lunga
ma è l'ultima
e devo premettere
che
l'ho tradotta io
ed è una traduzione
molto libera
perché è in rima
come deve essere
Brodsky ha sempre detto
le traduzioni
perdono per forza
delle cose
ma la cosa più importante
della poesia
è il ritmo
sono il ritmo
e la musica
e quelli devono rimanere
quindi è una traduzione
in cui certe immagini
non sono esattamente
quelle dell'originale
tenetelo presente
ma il senso è quello
vado
è una poesia scritta
cinque anni dopo
la sua cacciata
dell'Unione Sovietica
quindi nel 1977
si intitola
Quinto Anniversario
una stella cadente
in una notte chiara
mette a fuoco
il tuo sguardo
che non ha niente da fare
tu sbircia
sbircia là
dove non devi guardare
partito dal punto A
fra boschi
neve e ghiaccio
là il treno
si trascina
e cerca con impaccio
di arrivare
al punto B
di cui non c'è più traccia
là l'inizio e la fine
spariscono
come un gioco
là il defunto
è invisibile
e ogni grido
è fioco
fra gli uccelli
è diverso
ma gli uccelli
contano poco
là il crepuscolo
il pianoforte
picchia il bemolle
senza risparmio
la giacca
nell'armadio
là è mangiata
dalle tarme
là i cipressi
e l'alloro
li trovi solo
scolpiti nel marmo
là una pozza
nel cortile
è grande
come tutto il mondo
là tutti i giardinetti
hanno lo stesso sfondo
là l'irrequieto
don
continua a girare
in tondo
là il nonnino
ha sempre addosso
lo sguardo
del nipote
la spediscono
ancora adesso
in cielo
astronavi vuote
e altre piene
di ufficiali
che prendono
soldi a palate
là il verde
dell'aglio selvatico
disturba
il verde
della cipolla
il ronzio
delle api
la ti insegue
e non ti molla
per rispetto
dell'originale
l'ala copia
si rompe
e si incolla
là il colore
dell'inverno
è solo bianco
o nero
e i caloriferi
pieni di polvere
nell'anticamera
del ministero
hanno più costole
delle dame
e in generale
il forestiero
con la mano gelata
li tasta
anche più in fretta
là versandosi
il tè
va a finire
che ci si scotta
là la guardia
nel sonno
tormenta
la baionetta
là se accendi
un fiammifero
la pioggia
te lo spegne
la dicono
amici
alla porta
con un riso
di vergogna
là il pesce
ancora vivo
già puzza
di carogna
la votano
tutti a favore
con lacrime
di calcina
là le candele
in chiesa
affumicano
l'icona
l'esercito
ogni tanto
mena
i paesi vicini
la traboccano
dagli steccati
i lillà
lussureggianti
la birreria
tutto il giorno
è circondata
da muti assedianti
la quelli
che vengono dietro
assomigliano
a chi sta davanti
la fluttuano
nella stanza
avanzi
di vecchie arie
là il grano
prende un premio
poi finisce
nell'erbario
nei boschi
molte martore
e altre bestie varie
là anche se
stai sdraiato
con la pancia
per terra
ti vedono
lo stesso
su questo
non si sgarra
o almeno
te lo sogni
e nel sogno
la zavorra
è di zucchero
raffinato
con sopra
qualche cacca
di mosca
ma è un disegno
schizzato
sul cartone
e la mappa
del mondo
là sta al posto
di una vacca
che muggisce
su una roccia
là il tramonto
è come uno spacco
e là sferraglia
la fabbrica
nel fumo
del carbone
inutile a chiunque
all'astemio
e all'ubriacone
là sentendo
il grido
del gufo
gli risponde
la civetta
là gli applausi
intorno al capo
non restano
mai zitti
una faccia
intelligente
ai ai
spaventa tutti
là adornano
la bandiera
falce e martello
abbracciati
ma il chiodo
non è piantato
e il campo
non è mietuto
per dirla volgarmente
il grande piano
è fottuto
altri segni
lì non ce n'è
enigmi
misteri
complotti
il paesaggio
non ne ha bisogno
e l'orizzonte
è piatto
là è di moda
il grigio
colore eterno
è astratto
io son cresciuto
laggiù
offrivo
un mozzicone
al suo miglior cantore
ero carne
da prigione
abituato
a cieli
di piombo
e a bufere
fuori stagione
e credevo
che là sarei morto
di noia
o di spavento
tra le braccia
di un amico
o per sua mano
dipende
invece non ci ho azzeccato
e la cosa
un po' mi offende
insomma
non ci ho azzeccato
del resto
anche a teatro
lo sfondo
conta più dell'attore
il chilometro
più del metro
e da lontano
non c'è differenza
fra zampe davanti
e di dietro
adesso io non sono più là
e di questo importante viaggio
si stupiscono forse
solo i vasi
all'ermitage
la mia assenza
non ha fatto
un gran buco
nel paesaggio
una sciocchezza
un buco
ma in una tela piena
lo richiuderanno
il muschio
e i ciuffi
di lichene
e nessuno
noterà niente
un rattoppo
fatto bene
adesso io non sono più là
e se ci pensi
è strano
ma sarebbe
ancora più da matti
inchinarsi davanti
al sultano
tremare
e poi tramare
al tramonto
del tiranno
fare il pagliaccio
va bene
l'ho voluto
mio danno
io odiavo
la volgarità
non baciavo
l'icona
e su di un certo
ponte
il volto di ghisa
della gorgona
mi sembrava
in quei paraggi
la faccia più onesta
perciò
quando la incontro
adesso
qui
in questa
sua versione
ingrandita
non mi gira la testa
non mi trasformo
in pietra
sento la musa
che ride
la parca
sta filando
ma per ora
non mi uccide
lassù mi lasciano ancora
sbuffare fuori
a nidride
e la mia lingua
libera
golosa
di suoni
schietti
benedice il destino
in cirillici
versetti
e il mio destino
è
di capire
tutti i dialetti
davanti a me
c'è solo
spazio
allo stato puro
qui non c'è posto
per la penombra
la mezzaluce
il chiaroscuro
e che qui
non mi serve
una guida
almeno questo
è sicuro
stridi tu
mia penna
mio bastone
mio artiglio
non far fretta
a queste righe
sguazzando
nella fanghiglia
l'epoca
a motore
a noi
scalzi
non ci piglia
io non ho niente
da dire
né ad Atene
né a Sparta
la terra sotto i piedi
ormai mi sembra
storta
tu stridi
stridi
penna
sprechiamo un po'
di carta
e questo è
per Brozzi
praticamente abbiamo finito
due parole
perché Brozzi
è vissuto
dal 72
al
in America
degli eventi
gli eventi di questi anni
in realtà
sono importantissimi
se uno li prende
esteriormente
tanto per dire
gli danno il premio Nobel
per la letteratura
che non è una di quelle cose
e tanto per dire
e questo fa veramente
piacere dirlo
a 50 anni
sposa
una ragazza italiana
bellissima
italiana
di madre
russa
ma veramente bellissima
anche guardare le fotografie
fanno anche una figlia
insieme
però di tutte queste cose
su questo non ci sono
pettegolezzi
non ci sono
dettagli
non ci sono notizie
ci sarebbe
se avessimo tempo
ma non lo facciamo
ci sarebbe da raccontare
come la sua poesia
oltre all'intimità
continua a tener conto
di quello che succede
nel mondo
e specialmente in Russia
ci sono poesie terribili
sulla guerra in Afghanistan
sull'indipendenza
dell'Ucraina
ma noi
non ci fermeremo
su questo
come non ci fermeremo
sul fatto
che già nell'89
il governo sovietico
in piena perestroica
lo riabilita
gli ridà la cittadinanza
gli chiedono di tornare
non è mai tornato
poi gli pubblicano in Russia
l'opera completa
gli danno la cittadinanza
onoraria di Pietroburgo
lui non ci va
ma non ci va soprattutto
perché è molto malato
soffre di cuore
fin da quando era ragazzo
in America
si è aggravato
pesantemente
a 36 anni
ha avuto un primo attacco cardiaco
importante
con ricovero
a 39 anni
ha la prima operazione
a cuore aperto
su questo ha detto
una volta
dovunque vada
un uomo malato
un cardiopatico
in particolare
è destinato
a svegliarsi
di soprassalto
alle 3 del mattino
una volta alla settimana
o giù di lì
in uno stato
di autentico terrore
credendo
che la sua ora
sia venuta
siccome il tipo
lo avete capito
beve come una spugna
e fumo come un turco
e il 28 gennaio del 96
a 55 anni
a New York
muore di infarto
nel suo studio
la moglie
e gli amici
discutono
dove seppellirlo
in Russia
lo rivolrebbero in Russia
a New York
lo vogliono lì
alla fine dicono
ma ti ricordi
quella volta a Venezia
che ha visto
il cimitero di San Michele
e ha detto
questo sarebbe il posto
dove vorrei stare
io il tempo non ce l'ho
ma tenete conto
che Brodsky
è stato un giovane sovietico
il quale è cresciuto
certo che mai
avrebbe potuto andare
a Venezia
in vita sua
e però a casa
c'era una cartolina
di Venezia
dagli zini
ha trovata un'altra
e si era fatto
tutto un suo mito
di Venezia
sognava
dice
io sognavo
che un giorno
sarei riuscito a scappare
avrei rapinato una banca
sarei andato a Venezia
con i soldi
quando le avessi finito
mi sarei sparato
pur di morire a Venezia
appena è libero
appena è negli Stati Uniti
parte per Venezia
e per tutta la vita
passa le vacanze di Natale
a Venezia
tutta la vita
e quindi
alla fine
decidono di seppellirlo lì
e dal giugno del 97
Brodsky
riposa
al cimitero di San Michele
a Venezia
e si dice
che sulla sua tomba
quelli che vanno a trovarlo
lasciano continuamente
lettere
versi
matite
fotografie
e soprattutto
bottigliette di whisky
e pacchetti di camel
ma io non ci sono mai stato
e quindi
non posso confermarlo
grazie
ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo
allora
a Sarzana
grazie
Grazie a tutti